talk about stream multiplexing in go
actually I'm not going to do that I'm
gonna talk about something a little bit
different instead and we'll get to
stream multiplexing actually what I'm
gonna talk about is decentralizing the
web again since it kind of started
decentralized and then it kind of ended
up where for pretty much all of our
major services we rely on very few
providers so you're male like it's
probably Gmail or your file serving like
if you want to host files to access
anywhere it's probably box Dropbox
things like that and my question was
kind of like why don't we run our own
versions of these like why why don't I
have my own mail server anymore why
don't I have my own Dropbox like why are
why is all of my data owned by other
people and there are some good reasons
like content is a good reason like a lot
of the media that streams you are things
that you don't own things that you're
renting cost is another reason right you
have to actually like only the hardware
that runs if you want to run your own
servers and then like there's a giant
amount of operational pain with running
your own services and one of the major
ones is deploying services and so I I
want to talk about why that's a pain and
and how how they fixed so that we could
decentralize things again like I have
the computing power to run my own mail
server it's I have it like I have so
many old machines and all of them are
capable running like mail servers there
in my apartment but I can't run them
which is kind of similar to this
question which is why can't I assess
agent in my laptop like right now it's
running nested safe server but no one
outside of I don't know people on
whatever NAT Verizon has put me on can
actually hit at port and the reason for
that is is kind of embedded in this
quote which is what I imagined everyone
was saying circa 2000 which is how do I
connect more machines to the Internet
than my ISP gives me IP addresses and
the answer was well you stick an app in
front of them and so about 15 20 years
ago the internet changed the Internet
originally was intended for end and
connectivity between all devices and at
some point we real we realized that 4
billion addresses that ipv4 was not
going to be enough that we were running
out of addresses and so people kind of
became stingy with the IPS that they
were handing out like your ISP and so
when you wanted to have multiple
computers on your network or businesses
wanted to have like hundreds of
computers in their offices but didn't
want to pay for all the IP addresses for
them they turned to NAT and they turned
to them because well there weren't well
ipv6 wasn't ready and deploying Nets is
really easy the boy knives is its
unilateral no one else needs the
infrastructure around no one needs any
of the protocols around you just like
you just drop a box in an doors and one
of the major problems so it was kind of
this unilateral deployment thing any
other
kind of interesting thing to notice
about maths is that there's no standard
there's no API for them there's no
standard protocol for manipulating an
app for describing how it works
all your Matt's kind of by convention do
the same thing but they don't always do
the same thing some of them work
differently so we did that and it got us
to today that plan actually saved us
from it wasn't even a plan this kind of
a fine card is it actually got us to
today where we still are running all the
internet on ipv4 even though we have far
more internet devices than we actually
have IP addresses to allocate to them
but it came with some costs the major
the major cost was that it fundamentally
changed how we decide like how the
internet works there's not any
connectivity on the internet anymore
none of you can actually talk to this
laptop right now you can actually
deliver network packets to you to it
unless I do some special thing to let
you and that that head out so that's one
of the costs and kind of a corollary of
that cost is that all sorts of
peer-to-peer protocols became really
really difficult to implement like voice
over IP very difficult to do when it's
really difficult to get two computers to
talk to each other because there are
boxes Nats sitting in the way and also
meant that all the machines sitting in
my apartment that are are capable of
running things like file servers and
mail servers I don't have public
endpoints to run them like I don't
they're just sitting in my apartment
like I can try I can like log into my
router and my mine app and set up port
forwarding to get those things actually
running and maybe I can do that but the
vast majority of consumers cannot it
also means that heinous
so a related question is how do I
develop a service that receives web
hooks from any API that delivers Web
books might not seem like a similar
question to start with
it is though and so I built an grok it's
a service that solves that problem it
was originally a port of local tunnel if
any of you are familiar with that I
poured it in to go to learn go and the
basic gist of the program is it
establishes a secure tunnel from a
public endpoint on the internet on a
server that someone has like someone has
a server with a real public IP address
and it creates a tunnel that will take
traffic from that it's that's received
on that public IP and actually deliver
it to your machine so just as an example
what that looks like if you download and
run and rock-like port one two three
four it'll create a tunnel where any
traffic that it receives on some random
subdomain on and Rob comm will be for it
to your local port one two three four
one of my favorite uses of n grok though
is I get support questions about this
all the time which is someone's like how
do I run my own minecraft server because
someone figured out that you could and
put it on the Internet and then lots of
people became interested in that because
it's a popular thing to do and this is
the answer that's how you run your own
minecraft server on a machine like on
the machine in your house
but what if they were easier that's two
steps right that's like yeah it's three
like I have installed Java and then I
pointed I have to find the minecraft.jar
and then I have to download and rock and
then run that to actually set it all up
but could be easier could it be baked
into Minecraft where minecraft already
has this notion of getting a public
address to serve on instead of being
externalized to another program and if
you could do that with Minecraft could
you do that with all sorts of cloud
services could you have your mail
servers and your file servers and your
media streaming servers all have this
concept baked into them that instead of
serving on a local court that you could
pass an option to say I have a real a
provider of them out of the cloud right
who will actually forward all that
traffic to me so I can listen listen on
public IP addresses but I can still own
all the data that all of this all the
data's owned on my machine so what I
ended up building was an API for for
doing this for tunneling in go I built
it for and rock for doing the the web
hook sort of stuff but I wanted to talk
about the more broad like broad
implications of it so this is basically
what that API looks like in go it's
simplified but this is basically what it
looks like you dial some endpoint and it
returns to you a session object and the
session object gives you functions to
listen for connections and the this
things that the listener returns are the
the listening calls for return are
politics and you'll notice for those of
you who are familiar with the net
package that the tunnel objects
implement net listener so it lets you do
some cool things so this is how you
listen for new connections and go you
create the net listener you bind it you
accept connections and then
do whatever you handle each connection
individually let's get that one this is
you should notice that's the same part
at the bottom right that I'm connecting
I'm handling each connection listening
or and handling each one what I'm doing
first is I'm dialing out to an external
service and telling it to listen on port
90 90 so instead of actually listening
on my port I'm going to listen on the
port of another machine instead of
binding to a local port the the go
tunnel API is basically an API for
listening on ports on a remote machine
so actually do a little bit of live
coding so what we're going to actually
do here is I've set this up so that
basically anyone should be able to do
this any of you want to follow along on
your laptop's if you have them out but
we're going to actually write an HTV
server that listens on public addresses
from this machine so what I'm actually
going to do to start with is create a
really simple HTTP listener
I might have to refer to documentation
for this but I think we'll see if I
remember it
and then I'll bind a listener
let's have it like listen on 5050 or
something like that and then let's see I
want you actually have it serve on this
so this fails like panic out here and
then I want to actually have it serve on
that listener and I guess I'm gonna need
some imports for this so yeah nuts an
i/o and that it's baby what am I missing
oh so close
so that and
yeah dude tell about half thank you all
right hair programming all right so now
I'm actually listening on port 5050 yes
we can demo that oops I guess I put it
on a 50/50 one all right and then let's
change this so that it's listening on a
public address I'm gonna do here is use
the library is talking about this is go
tunnel and instead of listening on a
local address what I'm gonna do instead
is listen on a public address
and then we'll just do let us know where
it's serving
see where the
so if any of you actually try that
address everyone here should be able to
actually hit that URL so that's where we
get to actually stream multiplexing my
way over time okay all right let me know
it's like you need to like start playing
faster than that
all right so how that works is the way
it works in in and Rock today because
anger arc is doing something similar to
this is different I wanted to rewrite
that so that it was a library that I
could share so that people could build
services that just included a library
and suddenly were available on any
public like on the public Internet
regardless of where the device was that
was serving in and I was thinking a lot
about how that would be most efficient
so the way I ended up deciding to do
that was to use stream multiplexing the
basic idea is you establish a single
physical connection in this case the
connection is from my laptop to a server
that you know a hosted server in the
cloud and for every connection that I
want to deliver to this machine I create
a single logical channel that runs over
the physical TCP connections so there's
one TCP connection but there are many
logical streams over it that are
actually delivering the individual HTTP
requests that are made up to to serve
that page so I just made one TCP
connection or sorry I made one HTTP
connection to actually do that demo for
you but you imagine if you had a page
with like styles and JavaScript and all
that other kind of stuff you're actually
dealing with multiple concurrent
incoming connections so the basic idea
with three multiplexing is you split a
stream you split a stream into chunks
you send each chunk over the physical
connection with an identifier and then
you reassemble it on the remote side
this is the intuitive explanation this
is a conversation between
to people in some sort of instant
messaging program there's a single
physical screen it is the conversation
and individual pieces are messages right
one person is talking like they're
talking about going like to the park but
also telling a knock-knock joke but
these pieces are interweave and your
brain is smart enough to understand how
to piece them together you can
reconstruct the two individual
conversation threads here even though
there's actually only one stream with
exchanged messages
that's the intuitive explanation about
how that works so every stream that has
to be delivered to the other side is
being split into different parts chunked
up and identifier is being attached so
that the individual streams can be
reassembled on the remote side this is a
really old idea
it's implemented in a number of
protocols SSH is is one of them there's
it's also this is basically what the
framing layer of speedy does is this is
string multiplexing and there are a
number of old ones as well the original
like we're going to reinvent HDTV
again HDTV ng from 1999 or whenever
actually had this idea in it it was
called web MUX then instead of speedy
but it's the same thing and then even
before that that was like source from
some older protocols the other like core
is sort of like major player in this
space is SCTP this is an alternative to
TCP or UDP is a layer 3 protocol for my
purposes is basically a non-starter
because it doesn't work through Nats
Nats are actually rewriting the TCP
packets that you send through if you're
using SCP it's not know going to know
what to do with them and basically just
drop them on the floor for this for the
stream multiplexing that I wrote here
I didn't reinvent my own eye actually
but I did a little bit but mostly I
stole it the stream multiplexing that's
employed in Ingo tunnel is basically
stolen from a speedy and aged
bb2 so that's what that header looks
like you'll see the stream identifier
the 31 bits that's essentially what you
use to chunk that's like the header on
every message that you send through and
the identifier is what lets you
reassociate them on the other side the
reason I didn't implement like didn't
build this on top of speedy was then I
felt it was too complicated for what I
needed there are a lot of different
things in in speedy and HTTP to like
yeah there are a lot of different frame
types from what I really wanted was just
like the core simplest possible thing to
express multiplexing streams so you can
kind of dig into the implementation if
you're interested but these are like
four different types that are for
different set of frames that are used to
actually view the multiplexing and so
I've built it as a library the library
is on github it's called muck Sidhu it
is a general piece that provides you
stream multiplexing in go it's really
great for tunneling that's what I use it
for for go tunnel and the next version i
grok when I get around to building that
into it the basic idea is every incoming
physical connection gets matched with a
every like public connection that a like
the public server receives gets mapped
to a logical connection on the shared
stream that's between the server and the
client after I built it I also noticed
that is actually really great for RPC
I'll talk about that in a second first I
want to show you what the interfaces
look like if you actually use MUX to do
these are basically the interfaces that
you get you basically have a way to take
an existing net connection in the go
world and you layer on top of it a
session and once you have a session on
top of it you can open new strings you
can accept existing screens and
close the session as well you should
notice that interface looks a lot like
net listener because it implements a net
listener so you can actually like wrap a
single TCP connection and it then is
then a net listener that you can pass
and queue anything that takes that and
similarly each stream that you open or
accept from the remote side each logical
stream is also at once it it implements
net connection so you can hand that
around to anything that deals with in
that connections as well really quick
aside about our VC the interesting thing
I found out about it is it's a really
useful it's a really useful primitive
for situations where you're doing RPC
and you're like oh well so I have a lot
of these there are a lot of different
types of services that have the model of
I open a new TCP connection and then I
send across some sort of request to you
and then it receives a reply so examples
would be like at an O memcache read as
sequel like all these sorts of things
and if you want parallelism parallelism
out of them you have to open up multiple
connections and so then like oh well I
have multiple connections what I do with
them like I stick them in a connection
pool it's like why did you do that like
instead if you had the primitives what
you could do is for each of those things
that you wanted to run in parallel you
can just open a new logical stream on
the same physical stream you don't have
to deal with connection pooling the
overhead of these logical streams is
very tiny alright logical streams are
they're just kind of incrementing a
counter for the different IDs that have
kept track of it doesn't actually
involve provisioning anything in the
kernel so you don't have to deal with
pooling all that are kind of stuff I
kind of think of it as like a parallel
to thinking about user mode threads
instead of OS threads like the logical
connections are very late lightweight
just like user mode threads are very
lightweight to
but they're still kind of giving you the
same level of the distraction I think
I'm running really long on time but
that's a quick example of what the guys
looks like all right um
the downsides of that are that so the
downsides of actually doing this instead
of using doing stream multiplexing
instead of actually using physical
connections it's it's a little slower
the multitasking in your kernel and and
the and your actual hardware the drivers
for Nix is much better at doing that so
you're definitely gonna sacrifice some
performance doing this it's not
standardized I'm hoping eventually to
standardize what I wrote as like a yes
this is what a stream multiplexing
protocol should look like it's just the
bare minimum for what you need to each
stream multiplexing and the other kind
of difficult part about the other kind
of downside of it is that it suffers
from a problem called head-of-line
blocking which is the basic idea is if
you have multiple TCP connections open
and you lose packets on one of them all
of the other connections can proceed as
normal with this situation if you have a
single connection and you're actually
running multiple streams over it if you
lose a packet on the single physical
screen like all of your logical streets
are blocked the some people are smarter
at me at Google are working on a
protocol called quick which aims to
solve that by actually providing what
SCTP I didn't want it to give you but
without but actually would work on the
public Internet
so if you have this if you have this
power to actually like create public
endpoints to listen on from a library
like what can you do with it you can
start decentralizing the web the
applications that you build in addition
to listening on local ports should also
be able to with an option listen on a
public port write on a public address
just with a simple command line
which that is built into the application
so that people that people can run it on
like any any device that's connected to
the Internet can run any application
including services so the first service
that I built to demonstrate this I built
this library as I can and I really won't
test it out is a simple file server you
guys have used like pythons simple HTTP
server or something like that it's just
like that except it works publicly so
just for example like if you wanted to
see the source code for this I have this
command called Serdar this basically
just takes the tunnel that's been opened
and it passes it to goes a file surfing
the net HTV file server so you actually
go to that address all of you can
actually download the example code that
I wrote for this up a little on that
dress I guess I should provide like a a
nice one for you so let's do like I'm
going set so if you go to go SF that
server down that you can download the
example code for the presentation and
yeah moving forward I want to
standardize these protocols I want to
standardize the protocol for pursuing
multiplexing on a standardized the
protocol for establishing tunnels so
that these things can be built in other
languages I want to build a C
implementation and findings into other
languages so that projects in every
language not just go can build this in
so that I can talk to notch and
minecraft team and tell them like here's
your Java API just add this call and
your your minecraft servers will be able
to serve on public endpoints for anyone
to run out of their home if you like
so the other kind of thing is like there
are more situations than just Nats that
you might want to that you can't get out
of that don't have public addresses or
things that aren't ads that aren't
typically thought of them like not your
like home your router at home is an app
but there are other ones that are giving
me ideas about other things to build so
those are some of them I hope you people
I'm running TCP public TCP servers on
you
embedded devices things that you like
thermostats maybe that you put into
other people's homes but don't control
the network sue you just give them a
connection to the wireless network and
then suddenly they have a public
endpoint those are the links to the
libraries on github I'm in control on
the Internet's alright thank you